on this episode I scare someone and I
use my fake belt to consume an emotion
[Music]
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 115 of
the askgaryvee show
jury duty continues so I'm at of studio
by the way before we get into this show
d-roc you have to show this billboard up
here I don't know if you see this this
really pisses me off I love these guys I
know these guys I actually passed on
investing in their company in a
mayonnaise company Big Ups you guys
congratulations that's awesome to see
Javits Center in the background
d-roc truck is uh audio thing go ahead
you rock pick it up it's okay we can go
gray here for a second super excited
about the show really fun impromptu
video yesterday that I did that has
caught some good fire in the community
so if you haven't seen that dirac link
that up I'm making this video for the
people that are foolish right the ones
that tell me to my face every day that
yeah you know and really want it and
don't recognize the actions that it
takes to get there and India let's get
into the show
javi you're asked as a rookie how much
should I allocate to Facebook dark posts
for a teespring campaign Javier is as a
rookie which I like I guess a rookie
entrepreneur I would allocate a
disproportionate amount of money into
Facebook dark posts for teespring
campaigns especially if you make a
t-shirt that is very thematic meaning if
you made a t-shirt that was like Denver
truck drivers rule and then you dark
post against people that live in Denver
that are truck drivers as a profession
you will crush and so I think it's a
believable platform to convert on we've
talked at nausea on about this and as a
matter of fact I'm even going to go
completely in a different direction I
actually would challenge most people
watching the show right now that you
should make a teespring
and and and actually run a hundred
dollars worth of dark posts go long tail
with like teachers from st. Louis Rock
and learn the dynamics of specific long
tail Surgical Facebook advertising
because I think it will be successful
Paul asked how do you diplomatically
tell the boss he's effing it up post is
a good question i massively overvalue
the people my company who are
comfortable enough and saying like hey
Gary I don't disagree with you now a lot
of them walk into a buzzsaw
because they're wrong and then they get
clowned so you better make sure you're
right about the boss being wrong right
and so uh but I think I think any great
boss will be super pumped if you're
willing to respectfully point out things
that you massively disagree with and I
think it's a win-win situation for you
if you go down that route because if you
think about it if you give that feedback
to the boss and the boss agrees with you
maybe she or he knew that you were right
you've won points if they don't and they
completely disrespect you and the others
within the organization that try to get
feedback well then now you know you work
for a [ __ ] boss and he should be
looking for another job so to me there's
really almost no risk and going down the
route of giving critical feedback to
your boss especially if you don't love
love love your job and and more
importantly it's an amazing proxy to
audit your boss which i think is
massively important if you've decided to
put your career into the leadership of
an individual
yeah let's just move like let's just
move let me yeah let's move this way
because I like the way that people are
walking Josh asks which you prefer
abrasive versus compassionate when
getting a point understood some meet
goals and why Josh I'm curious why
you're asking this question I think it's
maybe because you realize I'm abrasive
and compassionate at the same time and
I'm very very thankful that I have a
tool belt where I pull out a lot of
different emotions competitiveness you
know caring warm sensitivity strength
disrespect one of my favorites such a
billet that was me drinking self
disrespect such a delicious flavor every
situation calls for a different
concoction and so what I spend most of
my time of really thinking about is
getting to know all the different
employees and trying to fit like that
stuff on like showed up in the back
I'm over here getting to know each and
every employee on an individual basis
understanding the situation at hand and
then being smart enough as the leader as
a CEO to deploy the right mix the right
blend at that moment for the task at
hand I actually have no emotion and no
favorite move nope I don't prefer
combativeness to compassion to respect
to any of this I really just use
whatever I think at that moment is the
right move sometimes I'll do six months
worth of compassion and then straight
karate chops sweep the leg to the mouth
because clearly that wasn't working so
I'm adjusting in real-time to my clients
to my employees to my investors to my
startups this is a never-ending
constantly 24/7 365 test and learn use
your intuition and and not get romantic
or not get into a habit of using one
move over and over because a funny thing
happens with these things it's kind of
like medicine if you use it too often it
stops working as well
Raymond asks how do you think people
will consume news in the future and how
can small publishers like ourselves
monetize on our content if it's consumed
on a native platform or even great
question you're gonna have to find ways
to integrand into great advertisers in a
way that if you're not the platform
where you're monetizing the eyeballs
well then you don't deserve the dollars
because all the advertisers want is the
awareness right I mean they're not smart
enough to recognize they want the actual
engagement in the cell through
unfortunately right now they still want
the awareness so if your news is being
consumed on Twitter and not on your
platform and there's no ad opportunity
for your advertisers in that format and
that's going to Twitter well then you're
then that's exactly what you are
alluding to I think what you need to do
is a find ways to drive people to your
world which is extremely difficult or be
rethink the model altogether do you
actually you know when was it that media
and news companies decided they were in
the advertising business a long time ago
but are you may be in the events
business are you maybe in the consulting
business or you may be in the content
production and compete with vaynermedia
business are you in the stand-up comedy
business I know that was weird but like
that's really where I'm going you and
everybody else selling news has
defaulted into I sell advertising why
why are you romantic about the way you
make your money why are you using 80
years of history to make your money when
the world is clearly changing at a scale
that we've never seen why why because
innovation and innovators are rare and
far and few in between aren't they and
so I challenge you in this show at this
moment and everybody else trying to
monetize news recognizing news is now
being consumed on Facebook
recognizing news is now being consumed
on Twitter you've lost your power of
people coming to your destination
there's a couple ways to think about it
are you thinking about virtual reality
video are you thinking about 3d printing
are you thinking about mobile only
Society are you thinking about the next
thing after mobile which might be I can
do it right here in thin air or more
importantly because all of that stuff is
probably 10 years away are you thinking
about different ways to make money
meaning you have a news outlet and
because you're good at producing news
and getting people to consume it on the
web maybe you help advertisers get their
content consumed on Facebook and Twitter
rethink that game and by the way that
was advice for everybody here always
rethink how you make your money Wine
Library has a big second floor right now
and I'm trying to sell it out of space
for you know events and things of that
nature I'm making money on the on the
real estate so rethink the way you make
your money
this great moment was brought to you by
the askgaryvee show askgaryvee show
watch it it was awesome that was a live
coverage show this show yeah like that
hey Gary's Jim Mitchum I have a question
about networking for the creative class
I'm a writer and I started my own
marketing consultancy in January and I'm
having an issue getting out and meeting
people you meet a hundred people before
breakfast
some of us don't have that kind of
personality so what advice would you
give people like me who have a hard time
getting out shaking hands and handing
off business cards what can we do to
help grow our own companies you have
anything
Jim that's a great question networking
doesn't come natural to give me my
headphones India networking doesn't come
natural to everybody and and the truth
is you've watched the show probably
enough to know I'm a big fan of betting
on your strengths versus working on your
weaknesses I believe people that are
more introverted reserved it's hard for
me to rar I you into going in like
shaking people's hands and rolling up on
people and being like hey oh no all
great you know like like that's not
gonna be what you do right that's not
gonna be what you do that's what I do
but that's not what you're gonna be
doing and so I would say put out great
content and and play the honey game
become the honey and let the bees come
to you instead of you becoming one of
the bees right and so I think that's the
game I think way too many people are
trying to be better at things that seem
obviously good and listen I spend a
disproportionate amount of time
networking much of which doesn't come to
fruition so that can be a waste
maybe you're saving a lot of time being
a creative doing your thing so I would
say for you and all the other people out
there that don't want to network hand
out business cards shake hands kiss
babies scare redheaded dudes I think
that you need to go out and put out
great stuff and let people come to you
let your work speak for itself I would
work in a b2b environment and try to get
your work seen in other places except
your blog that could be done behind your
keyboard on email to blogs and new sites
that cover the arena that you play in
that would be my advice to you let it
come to you
question of the day
oh I've got to go up question of the day
what are your fourth of July plans one
of the things that really matters to me
is getting to understand all of you more
and more and more and more so in detail
vaynernation
what is your fourth of July plants you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
also did you capture me scaring that guy
yeah you got it
it was good